Селище Хоуc у Північному Йоркширі
можна назвати трохи відлюдним, але аж ніяк не сонним.
Свого часу тут хотіли закрити
і пошту, і заправку, і бібліотеку, і автобусне підприємство.
Але все, як і раніше, працює.
Це його заслуга - члена місцевої ради Джона Блекі.
Громада взяла управління в свої руки.
Саме так село хоче кинути виклик "брексіту".
Нам вдалося стати столицею самоврядування, тепер нас так називають.
Ми будемо рятувати від закриття якомога більше установ.
Наприклад, ця комунальна заправка
приваблює відвідувачів своїм дешевим бензином
Хто встановлює ціни? Звісно, Джон Блекі.
По-моєму, він просто ураган, у нього море енергії.
Я живу тут уже 16 років,
і за все добре, що у нас було зроблено, ми вдячні саме Джону.
У свої майже 70 Джон Блекі встигає всюди.
Піклується про наявність доступного житла в селищі,
він почесний голова автобусного підприємства,
керує заправною станцією і навіть поштовим відділенням.
Можливо, вам підійде друге жовтня?
Жителі Хоуса вважають свою громаду цілком комфортною для життя.
Тут вистачає і бібліотек, і банкоматів.
Хоча сьогодні в усьому регіоні діє режим економії.
Джон Блекі побоюється ще більших проблем від майбутнього "брексіта".
У нас немає якоїсь грандіозної стратегії.
Ми вирішуємо проблеми у міру їх надходження.
І справляємося цілком оперативно.
І якщо яке-небудь питання можливо вирішити силами громади,
то ми це зробимо.
Наприклад, так жителі вчинили на початку 90-х,
коли місцеву сироварню намагалися закрити.
Тоді Джон Блекі мобілізував людей на порятунок підприємства.
Співробітники взяли управління сироварнею в свої руки.
І їм вдалося не тільки її відстояти:
сьогодні продукція компанії експортується по цілому світу.
Ми справжні чемпіони з працевлаштування в цілому Йоркширі.
Як і багато громад, ми покладаємося на туризм і сільське господарство.
Але в розвитку регіону працевлаштування грає найважливішу роль.
Багато молодих сімей все ж залишають Хоус.
Не всі готові боротися за розвиток селища
і життєздатність кожного закладу.
Нещодавно оголосили про закриття єдиного тут банківського відділення.
Серед селян - дещо тривожні настрої.
Не можна допустити, щоб у місті порожніли магазини та установи.
Тоді все виглядає таким спорожнілим, несучасним, запущеним.
Хто ж тоді захоче сюди приїжджати?
Але здаватися Хоус не збирається!
Адже ми повинні бути прикладом для інших сіл та містечок.
Інакше, якщо здамося ми, то й інші опустять руки.
Так просто ми не відступимо, правда?
Абсолютно вірно!
Ентузіазм Джона передається й іншим.
На його прохання 60 водіїв-добровольців
погодилися возити туристів і місцевих жителів похилого віку,
яким іноді просто хочеться з'їздити
на чай у сусіднє містечко.
Про Джона кожен відгукується з вдячністю:
це унікальна людина, якому навряд чи знайти заміну.
Я й сам хочу підшукати собі наступника.
Мені скоро вже пора буде закрити свій ноутбук і відійти від справ.
Я поки що нікого не знайшов, але не втрачаю надії.
Адже я оптиміст.
Ось за це його й цінують у Хоусі -
селищі, яке тримається на оптимізмі
й розраховує лише на власні сили.